j'adore aujourd'hui c'est le jour du
test du xiaomi mx3 ce smartphone avec
son beau slider le cheminement x3 est
franchement très bien réussie vous avez
un super grand écran et surtout ce
slider qui est vraiment hyper agréable
c'est un système aimanté à l'intérieur
la première chose quand on le prend en
main c'est vraiment un effet wow avec le
très grand écran c'est hyper immersif et
le couac le slider c'est un vrai jouet
c'est un vrai régal on aura envie
d'utiliser pendant des heures le
deuxième effet c'est de le sentir tout
de suite un petit peu lourd il fait 218
g on sent quand même relativement longs
moments à la main ça peut être un point
un peu bu l'eau quand on est l'ouverture
automatique due aux profanes dicks qui
reposait vraiment sur le logiciel ici à
rien car poste en logiciels donc pas de
risque de bugs pas d'espoir de plantage
pas le risque de problèmes ça c'est
franchement cool schumi a testé pendant
plus de trois cent mille cycle la
sensation d'ouverture est vraiment hyper
hyper agréable
c'est un système aimante et en fin de
compte à l'intérieur le boulot est
franchement bien maîtrisé très très bien
réalisé de la partie schumi là dessus on
n'a pas l'impression qu'il va s'ouvrir à
n'importe quel moment lorsque vous allez
jouer à des jeux lorsque vous allez
l'utiliser donc du point de vue du
slider franchement c'est top
d'autant plus qu'il est complètement
paramétrable vous aller dans les
paramètres et vous allez avoir ici les
sliders setting par contre je ne
comprends pas pourquoi ici s'est pas
traduit slider settings alors moi ça ne
dérange pas mais bon il ya des gens qui
font pas parler anglais
cider settings pouce de screen down to
text elfi et là tout est écrit en
anglais alors que tout le reste est
vraiment paramétrer enfoncé par contre
si vous explique ce qui est franchement
bien c'est que lorsque vous allez au
héros de sliders vous allez voir
différentes options prendre celle fit
donc ça vous ouvre l'appareil photo de
celle fils a du sens et moi open tools
hop voilà là ça vous emmène le cerveau
petit outil ouvrir l'application que
vous souhaitez ou alors carrément ne
strictement rien faire le mieux quand
même c'est pour prendre d'essai le fils
est franchement hyper cool en plus de ça
vous allez pouvoir paramétrer les son
examen de son attaque
warrior c'est la lame j'aime bien
mécanique intellect et leiter pour
briquer bon je pense qu'un autre que
vous allez pouvoir a ajouté plus tard
customiser les vôtres
c'est franchement intéressant le choix
qu'a fait schumi là dessus et de fond
sur la gamme mx c'est d'abord des très
grands écrans là on est sur 93 d'abus 4%
de la face avant complètement immersif
c'est vraiment un smartphone qui est
dédié au multimédia regarder des vidéos
jouer à des jeux vidéo vous avez un
écran de 6 39 pouces de diagonale une
résolution de 2340 par 1080 pixels à 403
pixels par pouce avec un ratio de 19
points 5/9 il ya un vrai grand bon
confort pour regarder des films des
séries pour du gameplay pour tout ce que
vous voulez maintenant le point qui me
déçoit légèrement
c'est le côté audio lorsque vous la
regardez des vidéos vous avez qu'à
agrandir franchement c'est hyper
agréable par contre lorsque vous envoyez
du son vous avez uniquement haut parleur
mono qui se situe ici il n'ya rien
d'autre pas d'autre part leur pas grand
fort avec les haut parleurs ici ça
franchement c'est vrai que c'est dommage
pour un flagship on aurait pu s'attendre
à ce que je suis on me met vraiment la
barre très très haut au niveau de
l'audio et là dessus c'est vraiment
dommage parce que c'est pas le cas en
fait quand on se dit qu'on va acheter un
flagship on va acheter ce qu'il ya de
meilleur ce que la marque fait mieux et
maîtrise le mieux alors très clairement
le slider extrêmement bien maîtrisée
l'écran et très bien maîtrisée
absolument aucun problème
mais pourquoi ne pas mettre des haut
parleurs stéréo c'est vraiment dommage
d'autant plus que c'est pas ça qui va
demander le plus de travail en termes
technologiques ne serait-ce que de
permettre aux petits haut parleurs ici
d'aller dégager un peu de son pour
ajouter importations immersive
on reste un peu sur notre faim après à
côté de ça lorsque vous jouez à des jeux
c'est franchement génial l'expérience
est vraiment hamas l'expérience est
vraiment top ici et pour jouer à un jeu
comme pays bg c'est vrai que c'est
franchement cool parce que l'expérience
immersive est vraiment vraiment vraiment
très très impressionnante après sais pas
si vous voyez mais sur le côté là toute
une partie qui n'a pas été développé
pour ce format d'écran donc on a une
petite partie noire c'est pas très
problématique mais c'est vrai que c'est
des choses que l'on pourrait espérer en
tout cas retrouver corriger côté
software c'est plutôt pas mal c'est me
why disent tout ça repose sur un android
9 paille
vous avez de la navigation par gestes
s'est franchement très très pratique
lowey c'est plutôt cool hop vous arrivez
vous avez si toutes vos applications qui
sont ouvertes
un petit soit vers le haut vous arrivé
là vous naviguez un petit soit il c'est
pareil c'est un smartphone qui marche
vachement bien sans latence avec de
belles performances
pour jouer à des jeux c'est parfait on a
un des derniers soc haut de gamme de
qualcomm c'est le stand dragon 845 alors
entre temps été présenté et les 855 mais
comme le smartphone a été annoncée
officiellement en chine fin d'année le 1
855 n'était pas encore dispo donc ils ne
tournent que je les liens que entre
guillemets parce que franchement le cndd
rigole 845 est vraiment bien et couplé à
6 giga de ram il et de la fluidité c'est
parfait pour des jeux pour tout ce que
vous allez faire ça ira parfaitement
bien et en termes de stockage vous avez
128 gia natif non extensible
un point qui est très important là
dessus c'est la partie photo vidéo vous
l'avez vu quand on ouvre la up
on peut choisir d'arriver directement
sur l'appareil photo côté selphy ça
c'est plutôt marrante à l'avant vous
avez deux caméra à l'arrière vous avez
deux caméras en gros les deux caméras à
l'avant vous serviront à faire des
selphy qualité et pouvoir avoir un mode
portrait vous avez une caméra principale
à l'avant de 24 mégapixels avec le super
pixels 4 pixels en 1 ça c'est cool et la
deuxième étant une petite caméra de 2
mégapixels qui l'a vraiment vous servir
pour apporter de la profondeur avec
votre mode portrait tandis qu'à
l'arrière vous avez deux caméras 12
mégapixels la première qui va ouvrir à f
1.8 donc il devrait fonctionner très
bien qu'on me sens faible luminosité
vous avez un autofocus duel pixels qui
vous permettra de faire le point très
très rapidement de déclencher des photos
extrêmement vif
si vous êtes plutôt vidéo plus que photo
vous allez pouvoir filmer jusqu en 4k à
60 images par seconde
après avez vous besoin de quatre cas à
ça c'est vraiment à vous de le dire et
en plus de ça vous pouvez filmer en
1080p en 960 images par seconde pour
avoir des super ralenti
donc ça c'est aussi plutôt intéressant
vous avez de l'intelligence artificielle
c'est à dire de la détection scène votre
appareil va vous allez prendre une photo
de temps vous aller pointer sur quelque
chose il va reconnaître c'est une plante
de la nourriture un chien chez ainsi si
vous fait tout ce que vous voulez pour
vraiment venir apporter la meilleure
colorimétrie est optimisé complètement
l'image
maintenant ce que je
pau c'est de faire un test photo vidéo
la vidéo c'est le cas justement je suis
en train de filmer mais totalement on va
se faire un test photo pour voir cette
caméra est vraiment intéressante
normalement ça devrait fonctionner on
est sans la même chose par rapport aux
mines x2 est donc c'est déjà une caméra
qu'on connaît qu'on a déjà vu que déjà
expérimenté mais bon on va les voir
quand même ça va des surprises
alors ça c'est une photo prise avec ce
mode portrait le décourager franchement
parfait j'ai fait exactement
complexifiant la scène cette fois-ci en
rajoutant au niveau des mains bon avec
un seul dragon 845 ça c'est franchement
maîtriser ça marche très très très bien
là j'ai fait une photo sans intelligence
artificielle sans hdr sans rien les
couleurs sont assez naturelle là par
contre j'arrive sur une grosse que j'ai
pris en photo c'est un peu pâle sur le
dessus c'est assez surprenant un vrai
rendu du détail là vous le voyez
notamment ici au niveau de la goutte
d'eau ça c'est quand même plutôt pas mal
les chaussures c'est pareil les couleurs
sont assez naturelle beaucoup de détails
ça c'est vraiment assez intéressant là
vous avez un art musqué prix sanjou mais
là avec le zoom x 2 on a vraiment des
couleurs qui sont préservés donc ça
s'est vraiment bien photos que la caméra
selphy avec les modes portrait et ambac
derrière ici c'est un petit peu flou
sans le mode portrait bon par contre sa
liste un peu la peau chez pas hyper fan
de ce type de lissage sa ses prix en
mode nuit avec donald qui vous passe les
amitiés moning également de nuit bon ça
va
le rendu n'est pas parfait au niveau de
la photo et la vidéo par contre ça
fonctionne très bien pour pouvoir sortir
tous les souvenirs vous voulez avec du
détail c'est cool pour shooter très
rapidement vous serez aussi très
satisfait la t shirt officiel donné à
côté un petit peu pâle sur certaines
photos après vous pouvez complètement
l'activé la désactiver c'est exactement
la même chose pour le hdr donc en
fonction des scènes que vous allez
prendre si vous voulez que c'était
complètement optimale vous allez pouvoir
choisir est vraiment faire la photo dans
les meilleures conditions sans aucun
problème et si vous voulez être beaucoup
plus loin vous avez même un mode manuel
donc ça va ça c'est intéressant comme
vous n'avez pas de caméra à l'avant vous
n'avez pas de facebook
il faudrait à ce moment-là l'ouvrir
déverrouiller refermée comme vous le
retrouvez un peu sur le au pot félix je
trouve pas ça hyper pratique du coup
shiomi nos amis son capteur d'empreintes
digitales situe à l'arrière qui marche
parfaitement bien
on aurait pu s'attendre à voir un
capteur d'empreinte digitale intégrée à
l'écran après c'est pas non plus
merveilleuse que le dos du smartphone et
c'est en céramique alors le dos est
franchement très
joli tout le dos en céramique capteur
d'empreintes digitales positionner ici
qui se prend très facilement en main
vous positionnez votre doigt dessus ça
déverrouille tout de suite ici bouton de
volume bouton pour l'allumer et pour
l'éteindre recharge en usb t-il ses haut
parleurs micro bouton d'intelligence
artificielle qui va activer ici google
assistants et qui marche franchement
parfaitement bien ici tiroirs de cartes
si vous pouvez mettre 2 4 nano sim est
ici un micro pour activer la réduction
de bruit est ce qui est vraiment cool
c'est à l'intérieur de la boîte vous
avez en plus le chargeur 10 watts sans
fil vous avez qu'à l'opposé il recharge
et ça franchement sympa qui est très
positif
comme malheureusement il n'y a
absolument aucune prise directe sur le
smartphone shiomi vous a rajouté ce
petit accessoire alors moi je suis pas
fan de ses accessoires la qui viennent
vraiment faire un truc vraiment pas
idéales voyez la branche mon casque vous
étiez cette espèce de protubérances qui
pendouille il y à du bluetooth 5.0 je
recommande là dessus de prendre un
casque bluetooth
c'est franchement ce qu'il fera mieux la
faire paraître accessoire kulchy omis
vous amis à l'intérieur c'est une coque
de protection alors elle fait pas
l'hyper hyper solide
on les sort un petit truc en plastique
mais c'est quand même pas mal pour venir
europe protéger votre smartphone c'est
franchement hyper hyper hyper cool comme
est-il de l'autonomie vous avez une
batterie de 3200 millions paire eur
alors l'autonomie c'est toujours truc un
petit peu délicat à définir parce que ça
dépend
franchement de vos usages si vous
l'utilisez de façon un peu standard
tendance à dire des jeux mais sans
exagérer écouter un peu de musique des
emails des sms des réseaux sociaux vous
tiendrez une journée sans problème une
journée lui pourquoi pas mais une fois
de plus ça ça dépend vraiment des usages
comme vous avez du nfc vous avez la
possibilité d'avoir du paiement
dématérialisé notamment google paye et
comme on a ce système de sliders on a
absolument aucune certification pas de
certification ip67 pas certification
ip68 après j'imagine que s'ils
rencontrent quelques gouttes d'eau il a
pas se mettre à s'arrêter à se mettre en
panne
si on résume ce smartphone est vraiment
bien parce qu'il a un slider qui est
vraiment innovant slider mécanique et ça
c'est vraiment impressionnant mais se
trouve un peu trop lourd 2
18 g à côté de ça l'expérience de
visionnage de vidéos d'immersion est
vraiment top
mais à côté de ça l'audio est pas génial
avec juste un haut parleur mono
donc est-ce qu'il faut acheter ce même
x3 est ce qu'il vaut le coup est ce que
c'est un bon smartphone du début 2019
pour moi très clairement c'est oui nous
fera oublier très rapidement ces points
négatifs parce que l'immersion qui va
vous offrir le confort de visionnage et
le confort de lecture est franchement
incroyable et moi ce que je vous
conseille
lorsque vous allez l'utiliser c'est de
prendre un casque bluetooth pour
vraiment profiter d'une bonne expérience
le v6 3 n'est pas parfait le mx3 est
loin d'être parfait mais par contre il a
des avantages qui sont vraiment non
négligeable qu'on va pas retrouver à la
concurrence alors on sait qu'en 2019 va
y avoir plein d'offres qui vont arriver
avec soit des toutes petites encoches
soit carrément plus d'un coach du tout
va y avoir des belles innovations
majeures mais pour un smartphone début
2019 je trouve que shiomi a vraiment mis
la barre très très haute estime que ce
smartphone est pour beaucoup
hyper intéressant j'adore il ya une
vraie sensation de robustesse là dessus
j'adore vraiment le côté slider dites
moi ce que vous en pensez qu est ce que
vous pensez de ce grand écran très
immersif
est ce qu'il pourrait vous tentez est ce
que vous aimez shiomi est-ce que ce mx 3
vous plaît oui ou non vous invite à
marquer tout ça en bas aux commentaires
à visionner ma playlist contenant tous
les tests de smartphones et bien
évidemment à vous abonner parce qu'on va
partir d'ici quelques jours quelques
bonnes journées au mwc à barcelone voir
toutes les nouveautés smartphones de
début 2019 et à mon avis ça va déchirer
d'ici là qu'on ait soit vous
s'embrassent ciao
[Musique]